Gilbert déjà merci d'être dans cette
émission une émission parce que des
vidéos vraiment c'est très très
courageux de d'être là vraiment c'est
super Laurent on va aller jusqu'au
délire super Montagné aux enfants de la
télé Philippe Croizon candidat à Danse
avec les stars on va jusqu'au dans ce
délire là et en même temps si vous
pouvez me jeter mon téléphone qui a rien
à [ __ ] là téléphone ici je ne sais pas
tu as un texto à Luna
il y a eu des articles qui disent oui
ils ont fêté les 2 millions de
téléspectateurs ils ont fêté les
audiences de TPMP alors qu'il parlait du
drame et donc il y a énormément voilà il
y a des journalistes qui disent oui
c'est inadmissible enfin c'est
inadmissible donc ils disent n'importe
quoi c'est comme si BFM demain se
félicite des audiences de la chaîne il
parle de drame tous les jours et on va
dire ah bah tant BFM il traite que de
drame mais il félicite de leurs
audiences bon on a entendu dans le débat
médiatique des voies demandant un procès
expéditif pour suspecte présumée de
Summer sans avocat procès qu'il a
condamnerait directement à la perpétuité
c'est remettre en cause tous les
fondements de la justice française
voire encore de la récupération pour
faire des articles
et autres parce qu'il y a des gros
journaux qui sont miston post etc
parisien ça a démarré sur des gens sur
Twitter qui veulent faire parler d'eux
essayer de faire parler d'eux sur ce
drame franchement c'est ici au-delà du
pitoyable aucun avocat n'interdira au
juge de prononcer la peine qu'il estime
de voir prononcer le moment venu
voilà c'est pas plus compliqué que ça
c'est la négation de l'État de droit
l'État de droit il nous protège
il vous protège il me protège il nous
protège tous
il protège monsieur Hanouna aussi et le
balayer comme ça pour au fond flatter
les basins faire de le dire de l'autre
dimanche moi c'est quelque chose qu'à
titre personnel je ne peux pas accepter
Baba
vous dit vous êtes dans un groupe dans
un groupe tel loyal au groupe il a pas
été loyal
que je me moque de cnews j'ai pas été
loyal il en a parlé six mois après et
mais le journaliste qui pour une fois
lui a répondu lui a dit mais attends
mais toi tu te moques parfois des
programmes et ça ce qu'on se moque des
programmes que c'est méchant et tout moi
j'aime bien parce qu'elle pro il a dit
mais nous c'est pas pareil on peut atpmp
parce que non une émission de
divertissement l'émission C'est des
records d'audience je vous le dis c'est
le seul truc qui dérange et que voilà ça
dérange énormément de monde mais nous on
continuera à être droit dans nos bottes
à vous enfermer à vous divertir et je
vous dire tant que les abrutis quand ils
en ont à faire des tweets et à faire des
articles c'est que tout va bien
qu'est-ce qu'un narcissique pathologique
précisément alors contrairement au mythe
qui a évoqué Stéphane au mythe de
Narcisse qui s'aimait trop le narcisse
pathologique ne s'aime pas c'est
quelqu'un qui a une trop haute opinion
de ce qu'il devrait être qu'est-ce qu'il
est drôle ça Nouna Hanouna avec moi si
tu as des enfants
[Applaudissements]
derrière attends mais ça se remplit
d'eau oh mais c'est troué
les gars j'imagine tes petites
coucougnettes mon lit
je salue Michel Drucker je salue
alors
il m'a dit je te regarde tous les matins
bon mais le problème c'est qu'il a dit
la même chose à Bruce tout ça
magnifique Michel Serres il a dit une
chose toute simple un jour il a dit mais
pourquoi aux informations ne donnent que
les mauvaises nouvelles pourquoi et ça
devait être un 21 mars pour qu'on ne
dirait pas qu'aujourd'hui le printemps
est magnifique regardez le ciel regardez
les oiseaux écouter santé et ça m'avait
bouleversé je me suis dit mais la raison
ce monsieur pourquoi Nicolas Sarkozy lui
était un grand jogger Chirac et
Mitterrand était plus coureur on était
plus sur des distances
Mitterrand attrapé Dalida Elisabeth
Tessier
grand coureur et par contre tu connais
Sarkozy c'est vrai qu'il fait des
marathons et vous savez qu'il y a une
étude qui a montré que quand il courait
21 km vu sa taille c'était l'équivalent
de 42
tu te lèves à quelle heure
je suis obligé
les enfants les animaux non mais même de
toute façon
[Rires]
que vous avez moi je ferme vraiment ma
gueule
[Rires]
moi il y a un philosophe que que
j'admire qui m'influence parce qu'il est
passionné aussi de croisière c'est le
philosophe sicilienne dans le
vitodicarlo parce qu'il a eu trois
citations qui qui vraiment sont ancrés
en moi donc la première quand on monte
on monte la deuxième quand on descend on
descend et la troisième qui nous
convient aujourd'hui quand c'est fini
c'est fini